has spent the last four months tending
to his farms hoping to profit from his
harvests but when torrential rains and
floods hit sudan's jazeera state much of
his land was submerged destroying the
crops have about 300 acres that were
farmed this season the rains and floods
have covered about 300 acres all what is
completely destroyed is a complete
disaster
some are trying to drain the water but
as a farmer this summer season has been
a complete loss
heavy rains and floods have affected
more than 90 000 acres in jazeera state
home to the largest governmental
agricultural project in sudan more than
130 000 farmers grow crops such as corn
and cotton for the country and
international markets but rain and
floods have affected that as well as the
economy of the state authorities say
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of produce have been lost
as farmers this is a loss for us this
season i'll not be having anything to
sell
the corn and anything else i planted is
gone i've lost more than a million
chinese pounds because of the flooding
and farmers income are not the only
concern the flooding of farmlands comes
at a critical time for sudan the united
nations says a third of the people in
the country or about 15 million are
already struggling to get enough food
and with flood waters covering tens of
thousands of acres that number may rise
even further
jazeera is known as the bread basket of
sudam supplying half of the crops it
needs any disruption in that supply
could raise market prices in a country
where more than half of the people live
in poverty authorities say they've put
plans in place to reduce the impact of
floods if it has a museum
we will split up the farming cycles to
make up for the losses the farmers have
incurred the amount of lands farmers
plant on during the winter season will
be increased based on the area of land
that has been destroyed by the reins
but farmers like
fear their lands may not recover in time
for the coming season and they may
suffer more economic losses
heber morgan al jazeera jazeera state